to celebrate mother's day we are
honoring some
awesome moms
[Music]
i'd like to tell you about karen monaco
she's dedicated her life to children
she's a high school teacher and a mother
of two who is giving back to her
community in a very
sweet way she's baking birthday cakes
for
underprivileged kids in her community
with the hope of
making their wishes come true so for
mother's day
we wanted to make this mom drew gooder
feel special with a little surprise
with the help of her kids check this out
my name is rita caccio i'm 11 years old
i'm from buffalo new york
and our mom is canon monaco my name is
tay picacio
and i'm 13 years old our mom is a
teacher
and she is also the chapter leader
for the buffalo new york for guinness
case chapter
my mom inspires me because she always
follows her passions and works very hard
we really look up to our mom she's
always caring for us and she's loving us
she's just like the world's greatest mom
and we look up to her
she's a very good role model and she
inspires us every day
i'm brian i'm karen's husband and we
have a package from the drew barrymore
show
let's go in and check it out and give it
to her you got a package from the drew
barrymore show
what i think it has something to do with
for goodness cakes
oh my god this is crazy
oh my god this is so nice
love it oh my god flowers
thank you so much this is awesome oh my
god
and spa find a gift card it's gonna be
so relaxing
oh my god thank you so much your brayboy
show this is great
i really appreciate it thank you karen
you are one sweet mom and we
appreciate you endlessly sharon eddings
a mother of three
has made it her mission to teach
children how to put down their video
games
and work in technology by teaching them
how to code and we want to thank this
mom drew gitter
for what she is doing for virtually
changing the lives of children
across the country one click at a time
take a look hi my name is almond smith
i'm the son of cher eddings who runs the
business of coding with shares
my mom came up with coding with sharon
when i was in the 10th grade
she had us learning new things on
computers showing the different things
she started making apps watching my mom
turn
coding with sharon into a business has
the
heartwarming she wants to teach other
people she wants to
teach the young black community around
detroit how to call
my mom has been volunteering for over
four years
teaching kids how to code and eventually
teaching
other adults how to code everybody loves
it every time she goes to school they
cannot wait to go to her class to learn
i want to say happy mother's day to my
beautiful loving caring mother
hi my name is jackson i'm 14. my mom
is sharon eddings she's an inspiration
to me because she's very strong
kind hearted i just want to say i love
you very much
and thank you for raising me and thank
you for everything
my drew barrymore got you a surprise
gift
wow oh look at this look at this
look at this drew barrymore it's
absolutely beautiful and it's so soft
it's soft
oh that's beautiful look at that
oh look at this gift card for five
hundred dollars i need to spa
thank you drew so much i really need
that thank you so much i really do
appreciate it
thank you sharon for shaping the lives
of so many amazing children
including your own i hope you don't mind
if i call you one day to teach my
daughters
happy mother's day we want you all to
meet ashley anderson she's the founder
of portland pay it forward a non-profit
helping to feed the hungry and her
community
and we enlisted her children to help
with a little surprise for her
so take a look at this my name is
isabella donovan and i am from portland
tennessee
and my mother is ashley anderson she
deserves to be recognized for the things
that she does
my name is autumn i'm the middle child
my mom
is one of the most selfless people that
i know my name is austin anderson my
mother
ashley anderson provides so much for her
community
she started portland pay it forward in
2015
and now has grown into way more than she
could have ever dreamed
my mom feeds 400 people every single
week
for thanksgiving and christmas she'll
actually gather meals
to pass out she goes out of her way to
do that and it's incredible
she works extremely hard and she's an
incredible woman and i'm
very proud of who she's become i'm so
proud of you mom
and i appreciate everything you do
she'll collect prom dresses and get
people to do hair and makeup
and pictures so that every woman and
gentleman feels their best on their prom
day it's just
it's an amazing thing drew please help
us recognize my amazing mom
she definitely deserves the world for
helping other people
[Music]
drew barrymore has sent her a package
and it just arrived
so let's surprise her
what is this this is from drew barrymore
are you serious my god
what is this that's for you do i get to
go to a spot
are you serious
this is so sweet thank you drew
barrymore
thank you thank you
ashley you really are a mom who does it
all
and learn how you can support ashley and
her nonprofit visit
portlandpayetforward.org i will be
frances chenoweth is a 94 year old
mother
grandmother and great grandmother
who has been keeping busy this past year
by making pillowcases
for children's hospitals around the
country
and she's today's very special drew
gooder
mother's day edition with her colorful
and creative designs
francis is putting smiles on hundreds of
children's faces
and inspiring us all watch this
i don't know what else you could ask for
a mother
she was just a rock in our family for
her whole life
she just loves people and she's showing
that love
by what she's doing in this pillowcase
project we asked mom if she might be
interested in sewing pillowcases for the
ryan organization
she immediately jumped on the project
and became obsessed
she loves what she's doing right now and
she amazes me that at 94
she can make three to four pillowcases
per day
and just wants to give her time her
money and her love to someone that just
doesn't have it and i have no doubt
that it comes from a place from her
childhood where she was in an
orphanage and then a foster child
herself she tried to give us
everything that she never had as a child
she's special
and we are so happy that we got her
what's what's that
we're really gonna do this oh my god
look at this
oh look at this oh my gosh oh look at
this
a spa finder gift
happy card day grandma grandma i love
you so much and thank you for inspiring
me
happy mother's day grandma we love you i
love her so much she's superwoman for
our family
she's amazing we love you grandma fran
frances you are so amazing i hope that i
can be as crafty as you are when i'm 94
i just want to be you jeremy gorman
is taking her love for literacy and
spreading it
all over her community in chicago
jeremiah is creating reading programs
book clubs
and even tutoring to encourage kids to
pick up a book
and get excited about learning starting
with her nine-year-old son
i have a nine-year-old actually she's
not nine but she'll be nine i'd like her
to get involved with this too take a
look
hi i'm james the son of my mom drama
not only is she the founder of burst
into books but she is
a science teacher my mom's goal is to
help kids
in my community get encouraged to
read more books and when quarantine hit
my mom jumped into action and helped
kids
keep reading she started a virtual book
club
and she started doing virtual beds on
stories
i consider my mom a superhero i love
that she is willing to help
other people besides herself i love you
mom
because you encouraged me to be a better
person
and you give me lots of courage to
help others in my community
hi my name is cheryl my daughter jeremy
just received a surprise gift
from the drew barrymore show let's go
see what it is
oh my god yes
oh you're a true glitter huh
[Music]
[Music]
thank you jeremiah for setting such a
strong foundation
for so many kids including your own you
are such an
inspiration to me and my daughters and
we should all
take a page out of your book happy
mother's day